we absolutely must
go over a bizarre and embarrassing
interview given yesterday to fox news
by former president donald trump and it
was
humiliating and embarrassing not just
for trump but
also for fox news which in the middle of
the interview
falsely reported the resignation of joe
biden's secretary of homeland security
just they just reported it in the middle
of the interview with trump then had to
walk it back
after trump had already reacted to it so
let's get into it donald trump kicked
the interview off
with really similar rhetoric about
immigrants to that of his infamous 2015
speech
about mexicans a lot of this vocabulary
will probably sound familiar to you
bringing the violence to our country
because many of the people coming are
not non-violent people they're violent
people many of the people coming
these countries don't send out their
finest and
in some cases i'm sure you have
wonderful fine people
but you also have criminals you have
murderers
you have sex traffickers you have a lot
of very bad people
coming into our country the theme in
this interview
was trump saying ridiculous things
with no pushback whatsoever from
interviewer harris faulkner
here's another example where again
donald trump continues to say he
actually won
not joe biden harris faulkner just
accepts it no big deal
policies and even you know i was um
i mean look we won the election as far
as i'm concerned we had a great election
we got almost 75 million votes but we
were going to
make it even more stringent with the
understanding that we want people to
come into our country but they have to
come in legally very simple
so let me ask you this i i want to get
back a moment and and
revisit the covid19 because that just no
pushback at all from faulkner despite
the fact that donald trump is saying
something completely
verifiably empirically untrue she just
moves on
then donald trump makes false claims
about
joe biden's policy at the border again
no pushback from harris faulkner
whatsoever oh
i mean it was just announced they're
allowing everybody
to walk through and just come in and
they're not taking
anything they have no information about
the people and then we get to arguably
the most surreal
moment of the interview other than when
trump said
i don't know why i'm here you really
called me we'll get to that
harris faulkner interrupts and falsely
reports
live on air that the secretary of the
department of homeland security
alejandro mayorkas
has resigned trump says well i'm not
surprised to hear that because things
are so bad at the border
and then harris faulkner says oh that
didn't that actually didn't happen
take a look at this this because it's
just happened now and i want to double
check this with our producers
um the dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas
has resigned mr president i'm not
surprised
good that's a big victory for our
country hold on let me
let let me stop let me stop let me
listen to my team one more time
forgive me forgive me that has not
happened
but uh and i apologize listening to the
team
where do they even get that literal fake
news being reported live
on fox news and maybe that warrants um
more
more discussion on its own trump then
hilariously says
joe biden isn't being transparent
what do you say about the transparency
with the current
administration well there is none there
is none
remember trump promised his tax returns
six years ago
never released them trump promised to
drain the swamp he didn't
trump lied about what he privately knew
about kovid
i could go on and on and on but trump
says biden isn't being transparent and
then donald trump is asked why are you
choosing to weigh in so
strongly and he just sort of says i
don't know you guys called me
really most presidents ex-presidents
like yourself do not weigh in at this
level
why did you feel like you needed to on
this issue
well you called me i didn't call you in
all fairness but the reason i weigh
in you wrote a statement last night it
was when i wrote a statement i put out a
statement
so an irritated sounding trump there
always just so
strange and then donald trump starts to
wrap up the interview by saying that
china is quote looking at woke that's
pretty unusual terminology china's
looking at woke
and then he says i don't know something
about dr seuss which nobody has ever
seen before
in order to accomplish the green new
deal nonsense
they're destroying it with woke when
china looks at woke and they see the
biggest problem we have is dr
seuss in the meantime they're building
factories and trying to
kill us in so many different ways they
laugh at us they think we're so
frankly they think our country is stupid
when they look at this when our
competitors look at what's going on in
our country
taking down the statues to great heroes
and so many other things
now i do it because i want to do what's
right
and they are destroying our country
isn't that truly something
china is going to be building factories
and trying to kill us so donald trump
trying to rehab
his greatest hits essentially while at
the same time
telling more lies mixed in
with a false resignation report from fox
news in the middle of it
having to almost immediately be walked
back i mean this is the epitome of the
trump interview
trump won't stop lying interviewer won't
question any of the lies
but reports her own literal fake news in
the middle of the interview
we'll have more on this interview
because it was so wacky and wide-ranging
uh on the david pakman show instagram
you can
find us there at david pakman show
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because
all of their shirts come with a patented
zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but
most importantly just overall it makes
the shirt
fit much better and look better the
carefully designed shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed
collar that won't fall down and lay flat
which i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout